- Making responsible
and effective COVID-19 viz is hard.
And so really quickly going to
go through a couple of places
where people kinda fell short
when trying to visualize COVID-19.
Some common pitfalls with
visualizing this data,
this graph was shown in a
local Fox News broadcast.
Aesthetically, it's definitely
not the prettiest graph,
but if you look carefully at the y-axis,
you'll notice something weird.
So the number is jumping
in weird intervals, right?
So this is not something we
really want in a y-axis graph.
And for those who know about log graphs,
this is not that, because you'll see here,
we're jumping by 30, 30, 10, 30.
Me trying to do math quickly is difficult.
30, 30,
50, 10, right?
The intervals are strange.
This is about 50 jump up here,
too, which is very bizarre.
I personally have actually not seen
a y-axis that weird and in a while
and it's kinda rare to see it that weird,
but think about the audience
in this case, right?
Someone watching TV,
their local news station,
is just looking at this graph quickly,
is taking in like, all
right, cases up here,
time is happening this way,
and they're looking at new cases per day.
And this kind of was shown in April,
so this was a while back
now, so don't, yeah.
This is a very low number
compared to where we're at right now.
But these inconsistent intervals
actually make these case
jumps on a regular basis
seem either smaller or
bigger than they should be.
So if someone is casually
just watching this on TV,
people can make their own inferences
and conclusions about that, right?
They're going to be like,
"Oh, this huge jump here,"
which actually, you know,
might not actually be that big
because of how the y-axis is being drawn,
might be like, "Oh, what
was happening at that time?
Well, then this must
have caused it," right?
Like there's so much
space for a casual viewer
to jump and make inferences
about what's happening with this data.
The other downside to COVID viz
is that if it's done kind
of lazily or not well,
it can be fodder for conspiracies
around the spread of COVID.
Many of these types of conspiracies
are supported by maps like these.
So what we have here
is actually two completely separate maps,
just sort of juxtaposed
on top of each other.
The top one is claiming
that countries, you know,
with 5G, labeled here in
this sort of red color,
seem to be overlapping with
countries that have COVID cases.
So if you look, actually,
there's a lot here, right?
But if you look really
carefully at this bottom map,
you'll notice that the
shading isn't, you know,
presence versus absence, it's
not just like one shade of red
and then sort of like beigey up here.
There are many shades of red,
but there's no scale to
indicate what that means.
All that's written here is
that red cases, or sorry,
red countries with hundred
or more confirmed cases,
and beige countries with
fewer than a hundred cases.
Granted, this was earlier
on in the pandemic.
A hundred cases in a country
is actually an important number
but it actually is more
what epidemiologists
use to mark the start of a pandemic,
as opposed to a comparison point.
A lot of data viz these days,
when looking at the
trajectory of the pandemic,
is trying to actually start mapping data
starting at a hundred days
or, sorry, the day at which
a country reaches their hundredth case,
because then you can reliably say
there's an outbreak in that country.
So that, already, is a weird dichotomy
to set up for this map.
The other thing is that countries
are kind of being labeled
just based on that one metric
without any kind of
consideration for population.
So think about it, right?
So if a country has a hundred cases,
but they have 300 million people,
that's really different than
a hundred cases showing up
in a country with 10 million people.
So right, already we have
a lot of issues here.
But fundamentally the
biggest problem here,
which some of you might've
already picked up on,
is this association.
So the person who made
this meme or whatever
put these two together
and is strongly implying
that these two things
are associated with each
other, are correlated.
Of course, we know that correlation
does not equal causation.
This cartoon is essentially indicating
this really common phenomenon
with issues with making maps with data,
especially in the United States.
As an example here, the maps
in the cartoon on the right
are arguably all much more similar
to each other than these two are,
but that's because they're all
actually showing the same
thing, which is population.
When you don't normalize for population,
you can look at lots of different metrics
that essentially just follow
where people tend to
cluster across a country.
So population normalization
is actually one of the
most important things
you can think about when making viz,
especially when you're trying to compare
the spread of COVID
across different regions.
That a photo of Trump I showed earlier
holding up that case
fatality rate bar chart
with the four countries,
so that segment was part of, I guess,
now infamous show of Chris
Wallace's Fox News program.
And so right after,
actually, that was aired,
Chris Wallace's show inserted
this sort of fact-check image
to highlight that, you know,
more than just four countries,
there are more countries on
this list, surprise, surprise,
there are other countries in the world,
so it now including Italy,
Spain, Brazil, and South Korea.
U.S. does not have
the lowest case fatality
rate in the world.
Again, this is not
comprehensive list of countries,
but it's at least a few more
than what the president showed.
And the issue here, right, so
a viewer seeing this is like,
"Oh, so Trump just like, didn't
include a few more countries
but the United States
still has a pretty low case
fatality rate, so not so bad."
But actually if you zoom in
on the top of this
little graph they showed,
so this is from Oxford
researchers who did this graphic.
They actually, you know,
the ones who calculated
this case fatality rate,
they weren't against assigning
too much importance to the metric.
This is kind of not super clear,
just 'cause of the quality of the picture,
but it literally reads, during
an outbreak of a pandemic,
the CFR, the case fatality
rate is a poor measure
of the mortality risk of the disease.
So, you know, the fact that
people are even using this
as a metric for assessing how
dangerous this diseases is
is somewhat flawed.
But again, right, like
that's just a nuance
that the viewer is just not party to.
They miss that entirely
because this is just a series of lines
and they're looking for the lowest one.
So we looked at a couple of examples
of kind of viz having some
issues with COVID spread,
and there are plenty more
examples out there of this.
Oftentimes, you know, some of
the mistakes are inadvertent.
Most of the time actually,
I would say they're
inadvertent and not malicious,
but again, this is the job of the person
creating the visualization
to do this responsibly.
Oftentimes for something like COVID,
it's not just on one person.
We have, typically teams
of people working on this.
You have epidemiologists, policy makers,
like all interfacing with designers
to actually collect the
expertise into one place
and create the best possible
and most informed visualization.
And that was definitely the case
for the Financial Times
data journalism team.
So these graphs became really
really popular line graphs,
became very very popular
since they kind of started
popping out in March.
So John Burn-Murdoch, who
works at the Financial Times,
on March 11th, tweeted this
line graph, which initially,
I think they're now like
50 iterations of this now.
It's many, many versions,
but initially this was
showing the cumulative number
of COVID cases in major countries.
The Federal Times has a European tilt,
so some more European
countries are listed here.
His graphs were unique in that
he used a logarithmic scale,
which is actually quite good
because mainly viruses spread
exponentially over time,
and so this allows for a more clear
direct comparison across countries.
You can imagine if this
weren't logarithmic,
you'd have this kind of weird big slope
for every one of these countries,
that's sort of redundant
for that initial sort
of exponential phase.
And so comparing countries more directly
and using the kind of
real estate of the graph
is kind of enhanced by
using the logarithmic scale.
There are also a lot of
really good design choices.
I'm not gonna spend too much time today
talking about, you know, color
theory or accessible design,
but these are actually really
important things to consider
when you're getting into data viz.
I'll talk a little bit about
that in the coding video,
but a couple of things here that are great
is sort of the color scheme
that John is using here
is really distinctive and
kind of very appropriate
for what he's trying to show, right?
The lines themselves are colored in a way
to draw attention to the data.
The fonts are all clear and clean.
The graph itself is extremely minimal,
so there's really like no clutter,
like you have the absolute minimal
kind of information you need.
So you're not kind of like
spending a lot of time
trying to visually try to figure out,
not a lot of cognitive work to figure out
like what really is happening, right?
And the really, really great
thing that John did with this,
that a lot of great, you know,
data viz practitioners do
is to use annotations.
So here you can see he's written
in a couple of notes here.
So for South Korea, Japan,
Singapore, Hong Kong,
he has this sort of
dotted line to indicate
the 33% daily increase
like, this is what that is.
And so, you know, if a
line is sort of wavering
above the 33% line,
you know they're sort of in
this one category of spread
and if they're below, you know
that's more where a country
would want to be.
And so without these
annotations, someone would ask,
"Okay, so what makes South Korea, Japan,
Singapore, Hong Kong so special?"
Without the annotations, the
audience has to do that work
or imagination or whatever it is, right?
But John is doing that
work here for the viewer
by putting in specific policy measures
that different the countries have taken
as well as some caveats
as well, too, right?
So for example, South Korea
spread slowed from initial pace,
but it's picked up again,
so it's not like all happy-go-lucky there,
and Japan's rate is low,
but there's debate about whether
enough tests have been done
to kind of capture the real spread.
Singapore, Hong Kong,
super super low spread,
both having strict quarantining
and very rigorous contact tracing.
Hong Kong also having
rapid school closures.
So this is just a very
simple kind of example
of how you can just add a
little bit extra to a graph
to really make it compelling
and provide that context.
The kind of like point
of this graph, right,
was John has talked to us quite a bit
about his series of graphs,
is to drive the
inevitability of Coronavirus
and how countries are sort
of going down this same path
as Italy was at the time,
which was considered sort of ground zero
for Europe for COVID,
when they don't adopt certain
public health measures
like quarantines and robust testing.
And Financial Times team plus John,
they went on to make graphs like these
for a bunch of other metrics
that became, you know,
rapidly, as teams kind
of work together, right,
this is part of like what working
in a collaborative group does.
You had epidemiologists being like,
"Well actually this measure
is really good to look at as well, too."
So things like excess deaths,
hospitalization, ICU capacity,
these are all very unique
and different metrics
with which to look at
the spread of COVID-19.
On the flip side, right?
The problem with putting
out a viz to a public space.
So John tweeted this out,
the graph I showed before,
is that there's always room for some sort
of like appropriation
or recontextualization.
So this was a few weeks later.
John had another graphs, again,
it's another cumulative number of cases.
Number of days since
hundredth case, remember that
I mentioned as being kind
of like the gold standard
for, this is when the
country has an outbreak,
so we're gonna start counting from here.
Someone saw John's graph and was like,
"All right, I'm gonna
circle all of the countries
with this lower trajectories,
lower spread of cases
and the ones above and just
give them their own sort of,
you know, annotation."
In this case, it's no masks versus masks.
This is obviously a really
aggressive simplification
of the differences between
two sets of countries
and it's kind of masked by the
big red and big blue circles,
but there are a lot of countries
in this no mask category.
There's the U.S., there's Turkey,
there's the UK, Brazil, Spain.
I guess Italy is kind
of in there as well too.
And so I think it's not too difficult
to see how those countries
cannot all be sort of summarized
into mask, non-mask adhering countries.
If we know anything, we know mask wearing
is something that is extremely variable
across populations within a country,
let alone across countries,
but there are other things happening
in each of these countries.
Like I mentioned, mitigating
factors like policy changes,
demographic differences,
things like that, right?
Whether or not quarantines
were being enforced,
test and trace programs,
all of this stuff is happening
at the same time as data collection.
And so for someone to
go in and just be like,
"Well, solved this problem.
It's no mask versus mask,"
is a gross simplification.
The sad thing is, underneath
all this kind of like garish,
like annotation, John
actually did a lot of work
to annotate the different countries
to kind of provide context
for what's happening
in different countries.
But, you know, when you're
sharing something on social media
this is something to be really wary of
because people want to
apply their own narratives
to data that they see.
This is something that's
happened time and time again.
People come in to looking at data
with their own preconceived biases,
and they love data that kinda confirms it.
Even if it doesn't actually confirm it,
they can kind of warp and annotate things
to fit their own narratives.
Another phenomenal example of
COVID-19 viz this past year
has been from the Reuters graphic team.
So again, strongly,
strongly, strongly recommend
all of their work, it's
absolutely gorgeous.
They have a live Coronavirus case tracker
in the United States, which is
one of my personal favorites.
So this is updated regularly.
I'm looking at it right now,
updated today, January 4th.
And yeah, I'm just gonna
scroll through this
just to highlight a few things here.
So yeah, I first wanna say
like a very common thing
with data viz that you'll
see online that's wonderful,
I'm gonna show a couple examples of this,
is what's called scrollytelly,
which is kind of a silly phrase,
but the idea is, much the way you read
like any kind of article online, you know,
you're scrolling through a page.
But instead of just text,
you're getting visuals to
provide context and distill data.
So in this case, this is
sort of what Reuters does.
The thing I wanna focus
on their tracker page,
there's a lot more on this page,
is their sort of mini
map across the states.
So here, right, you probably recognize
this is a representation of
the United States of America.
Each state, instead of being a state,
is represented by a trend line.
Again, a line graph, so
time being on the x-axis,
and the y-axis is the
weekly reported cases
per 100,000 in the population.
So right away, we see that
this is a normalized number.
And why is it normalized?
Because that was what makes
it comparable across states.
There are states with a lot of people
and there are states with
not that many people.
So if you don't do this
type of normalization,
your comparisons are gonna
be completely messed up.
The other cool thing here for the users,
that you can actually flip
between an adjusted scale
and a uniform scale.
And so what this means, you might be like,
"Oh, that's a cool
feature, you can toggle."
So Reuters actually tells you.
It's pretty small down here,
but your uniform scale shows
all the states on the
same vertical axis, right?
So imagining these are like
pure case numbers, in a way,
so that they're comparable, right?
New York having this many
cases and this many cases,
and things like that,
versus the adjusted scale,
which emphasizes the
trajectory in each state
by recalibrating the vertical axis
according to the state's
highest weekly figure.
So this is more of like,
this is the shape of the pandemic
trajectory in this state.
And this is a more kind of like,
if we're gonna set the
scales to be uniform
across the different states.
And the other feature here,
so this is a little like
kind of yellow shading
where cases have risen
for more than two weeks.
So in this case, New
York, Virginia, Georgia
are highlighted here.
This obviously changes over time.
Over the course of the pandemic
this has looked very different.
But these are helpful metrics, right,
to kind of compare severity
and kind of aggressiveness
of the spread of the pandemic.
The other feature here,
a lot of the stuff I was showing before
was cumulative cases,
so like literally raw numbers of cases.
But what this is, is
weekly reported cases.
So this is at the end of every week
as of Sunday each week.
These are the sort of
cases for that batch.
The reason why this is done weekly
is to kind of distill
the potential effects
of any single day being
a particular problem.
So one very common issue with COVID data,
departments of health
across different states,
and countries of course,
collect data very differently
and individual days might
have issues with reporting.
So a country can simply just, you know,
a country, excuse me,
a state can have like a
data entry issue one day.
Maybe, you know, we just had the holidays,
like there could have
been a lag in reporting.
There could've been like a system failure
with like where the data was stored.
Like there are a whole bunch
of things that could happen
with data entry or there
could be like an actual issue
with the way in which data is collected.
So maybe data was
initially classed as tests
and said those were cases
and stuff like this happens.
And so you wanna kinda remove the noise
of individual days and so this
is why it's weekly reported
cases as opposed to daily cases.
And another phenomenal
data viz from this year
was from Harry Stevens
at The Washington Post.
Again, their graphics team is phenomenal,
so definitely recommend their work.
This was a very, very cool and
unique type of visualization.
So this was at the very
start of the pandemic,
since this was March 14th.
This actually became the
number one most visited site
in The Washington Post's
site history ever.
It's translated into many languages now,
so you can see here.
And so really briefly,
I'm gonna jump through this page.
Again, it's one of these
like scroll-type situations.
And what this was trying to do
is to essentially use simulations
to explain how the virus spreads over time
by creating the sort of
fake virus called simulitis,
kind of acting in lieu of COVID.
But just to understand, you know,
why actually social distancing measures
and measures like those actually work
to flatten the curve per se, right?
So right, this starts off, again,
this is a while ago now.
It feels like years ago,
but this was sort of like how cases
initially kicked off in the U.S.
It does a really good job of breaking down
some of the jargon around
COVID, initially, too,
which I'm sure would be helpful
to kind of any person reading it.
But the idea here, right,
they create a fake disease, simulitis.
The idea is that it spreads pretty easily,
so whenever a healthy person
comes into contact with a sick person,
that healthy person becomes sick too.
Just like this, kind of
just like when one of these
little like balls of virus,
balls of people, I should say, touch.
It's pretty quick for everyone
to catch this fake disease.
But then, of course,
people recover over time.
So again, this is a situation
where we're making assumptions.
This is not COVID.
People are also actually
dying of the disease too,
but this is assuming that people
are recovering from the disease.
And so just to highlight
the spread of this, right,
essentially the way
this visualization works
is Harry is having simulations run.
So it's a new simulation
every time you run it
of what happens to the
kind of recovered, healthy,
and sick population under
different scenarios.
So in this case, yeah, we have,
it's a little bit glitchy,
so sorry about that.
A lot of people are
getting sick pretty fast.
This curve is big.
Over time, people do
recover, but you know,
a lot of people had to get
sick first for this to happen.
And this is a relatively small population.
There are 330 million
people in the United States,
so that curve would
steepen for a long time
before it started to slow.
Now, in a case that China
tried in the Hubei province,
they tried a forced quarantine.
So this is sort of what
that simulation is like,
where we quarantine off
the sick population.
But of course, forced quarantines
actually don't really work
because, as Harry mentions
here, it's not realistic,
so people can't actually
be quarantined entirely
and there are always going to be leaks.
And so those leaks eventually
impact the rest of the population.
What happens when 3/4 of a population
adopt social distancing?
So you see some of the
balls sort of stop moving
while some of the other little
balls continue moving around,
and let's see what happens
with this trajectory.
We're literally seeing the
flattening of the curve
happen in real time in the simulation.
So, you know, right
around this time in March,
there was a lot happening
with that flatten the
curve kind of mantra.
But a lot of people were like,
"Well, why, I don't really get
why I'm doing this entirely.
Like I sort of get like I'm supposed to,
but it doesn't make sense."
And so this did a really really good job
of explaining this kind
of public health stance
that was taken early on in the pandemic.
Where even fewer people are moving around,
so just one out of every eight people
are moving around while other people
are sort of social
distancing in this case.
And that curve is about as
flat as it can be in this case.
Again, this is a fake disease.
There are so many other
kind of aspects to COVID
that are different than this.
But in terms of conveying
of pretty complex
epidemiological and public health concept,
this does really really
good job of distilling down
why things like social distancing work
even if at a moderate level.
So, right, as a summary of this, you know,
how flattening the curve
can look like in real time.
This is sort of what we experience
and these simulations are, again,
this is generated every
time someone loads the page.
And so there's this really kind of like
strong interactive feeling to this
and exploring different cases,
different conditions to see like outcomes
and how data changes
according to those outcomes.
And probably my favorite
set of visualizations
from the New York Times
graphics department.
They produce some of the
absolute best data viz
that I've ever kind of seen.
And their COVID work was remarkable,
some of their best work.
They had a sort of pair of articles,
"How the Virus Got Out,"
which was sort of from the China end,
exploring the viruses trajectory
out to other countries.
But the "How the Virus Won" story
is the one I wanna focus on
because this is focused
on the United States.
So I'm gonna just
quickly skim through this
and highlight a few things
that this does extremely well.
So again, this is just sort
of the scrollytelly format
where you're scrolling through
and you're kind of getting new information
broken down into kind of
like bite-sized chunks.
And so this makes it very,
you know, easy to digest
for someone just kind of
coming in and being like,
"I don't know how to ingest this data."
So the flip side to the static graphs,
which are also great, 'cause
they're just, you know,
very kind of efficient.
You just kind of like see it
and you'd get your takeaway.
Interactives take take a
bit more time to go through,
but they can kind of, in that respect,
cover a lot more ground.
And so starting off from the
first cases in the States,
known cases, I should say,
and sort of following
the story of those cases.
But then actually tracking this on a map,
talking about hidden infections,
which we now know was a huge problem.
We didn't have adequate testing,
so we did not know and have
any sense of the spread
of this disease at the outset.
Over 2,000 infections spreading
throughout major cities.
And we tried some travel restrictions,
but they weren't full bans.
Lots of infected travelers coming in
from the rest of the world, right?
'Cause this has already
been spreading for a bit
and seeded initial
outbreaks in the country.
And then over this kind of critical window
that now we were very familiar with
where we didn't have the kind of testing
to understand the extent
of these outbreaks.
Meanwhile, the virus is
just spreading very happily.
And again, this is also being paired
with what else is
happening in the country.
Policy decisions, changes in travel
that don't really kick in
really until March, right?
And so from March 1st to March 14th,
a lot of people are still moving
very normally across the country.
This is cell phone data.
So now we're getting into
this really cool thing
the New York Times does,
is overlaying different types of data.
And throughout this, right,
they're also making, you know,
they're pausing with each
new dataset and saying,
"Hey, this is this data we have,
this is how it's aggregated,
this is the data source,"
which is really important to do
for someone just kind
of like coming into this
and not really knowing
what to get out of this.
Again, you have date
stamps for everything.
We're zooming in on specific locations
to get a better picture.
The text blurbs are very helpful
to kind of frame the data story.
And also throughout this,
I'll say like the kind
of color choices here
are very powerful, right?
Your eyes immediately
go to these very stark
kind of the blue, the red,
they're not these kind of like
bold sort of blue red colors.
They're muted in a way,
but everything else is sort of minimalized
to be absolutely essential,
again, to declutter the picture
and to focus on the critical parts.
Love the great quotes in here, too,
from politicians who made choices.
This is one of the, in my opinion,
one of the most powerful pieces of viz
that the New York Times did
because it does this very
kind of like whole picture
look at what was happening at
every stage in this process.
And then even beyond
travel, movement data,
now we're getting into the
actual genetic mutation data,
a whole 'nother type of data, but right,
they're able to take this, as well, too,
to study the spread
and talk about different
variants of COVID.
Again, visualizing this in
an extremely compelling way.
And by March 13th, when the
lockdowns kind of started,
and that was when travel
was limited from Europe.
The outbreak was already
kind of, you know,
in full force across the country.
There's obviously a huge amount of data
that goes into what they're showing
in terms of hotspot
data across the country,
where cases are breaking out,
but the story also stops
and takes a minute to look
at very specific cases.
So in this case, centering
on this one woman
who traveled from New Orleans
where we now know there was
an outbreak at that time
to Memphis, helping seed a case there.
So again, this is something similar
to what the Washington Post piece did,
in that they distill things
down to the individual level, right?
One ball kind of infecting another ball.
In this case, it's how
one person's movement
went and then seeded
an entire new outbreak.
And in many ways, this is kind of similar
to that kind of like abstract
balls floating around,
but the context here with the text,
this is real data.
This is not a fake virus, right?
Of who was traveling where,
what was it's happening in
the country at the time.
And this is when the
lockdown sort of kicked off.
This article came out in June,
and so this was tracking
sort of movement over time.
I'm also going through this very quickly,
so please take your time with this.
I just wanna kind of highlight
some of the the cool things
I liked about this piece,
that are really powerful.
Again, the color is really very minimal,
but it's powerful
because it's highlighting
the most specific and important
aspects of this story.
So we kinda slowed exponential growth
from those early reductions of movements,
and just thinking back
to those simulations
of flattening the curve.
Being in New York City, right,
this is specific to
what was happening here.
Again, going back to the idea
that different regions
are very hard to compare
unless you control for
many different factors.
So the kind of politics and
logistics and infrastructure
of New York plays a very
different role there
in how daily life is affected.
It's not just the disease at play.
Kind of continuing now to the deaths data.
So before it was cases,
and now move to deaths,
which of course were
extremely, extremely bad,
April, May, in New York City.
And this piece of data
viz also has a point.
At this juncture, there
was the main kind of story
of not enough testing
happening in the country,
and so this story has this message
of we don't actually
know how bad it can be
because we still can't, you know,
test the people that we need to test.
And this has been a problem to this day,
but at the time that was
extremely problematic.
Testing hadn't really ramped
up to the level it needed to.
And, you know, by late June,
we had outbreaks seeded
across the west and south.
And this might be the part
people tend to gloss over,
but this is actually really
really important for data viz.
This is a really intense
rundown, and detailed rundown,
of exactly how they did
everything they did here, right?
How they estimated different sets of data,
how they collected different sets of data,
the limitations of different sets of data.
I'm not gonna go through
every single one of these,
but right, who they
collaborated with, right?
There are so many different people
they're interfacing with here.
So there are scientists they're talking to
for the genetic samples,
companies that are collecting
different types of data,
the cell phone data that was collected
to kinda capture movement.
But again, there are limitations
to all these things, too.
How they classify different
areas and then conclusions
and quotes from even
politicians as well, too.
And on top of that,
more sourcing for their
story as well, too.
So this is just like
extremely comprehensive way
of telling a story.
This is obviously not
your typical data viz,
but it's a kind of like gold standard
for how we can break down the story
of the spread of the virus
in an extremely, extremely thorough way.